Malgré tous nos efforts,
seulement 9 % du plastique que nous utilisons est recyclé.
Pire encore, le plastique est incroyablement résistant et durable,
et les chercheurs estiment
qu'il lui faut entre 500 et 5 000 ans pour se décomposer totalement.
Il relâche des contaminants dangereux dans nos océans, nos terres,
notre nourriture, notre eau et en nous.
Alors, comment nous sommes-nous retrouvés avec tant de déchets plastiques ?
Eh bien, c'est tout simple.
Le plastique est bon marché, résistant, adaptable,
et on en trouve partout.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'il existe autre chose
également bon marché, résistante, adaptable et partout,
et mes recherches montrent qu'elle pourrait même nous aider
à résoudre notre problème de pollution plastique.
Je parle des bactéries.
Les bactéries sont des êtres vivants microscopiques,
invisibles à l'œil nu, qui vivent partout,
dans toutes sortes d'environnements différents et extrêmes.
De l'estomac humain, à la terre, la peau,
les évents hydrothermaux pouvant atteindre des températures de 400 °C,
les bactéries vivent partout,
dans tout un tas de conditions différentes et extrêmes.
Par conséquent, elles doivent être plutôt créatives pour trouver leur nourriture.
Elles sont aussi en très grand nombre.
Les chercheurs estiment qu'il y a environ 50 millions de billions de billions -
c'est-à-dire cinq suivi de 30 zéros -
de bactéries sur notre planète.
Donc, sachant que nous, humains,
produisons 300 millions de tonnes de nouveau plastique par an,
je dirais que la quantité de plastique
est assez comparable au nombre de bactéries.
Donc, après en tel constat et la découverte
de toutes les manières créatives dont les bactéries se nourrissent,
j'ai commencé à me demander :
est-ce que les bactéries vivant dans un environnement pollué par le plastique
ont trouver le moyen de l'utiliser comme nourriture ?
Eh bien, c'est la question que j'ai décidé d'étudier, il y a environ deux ans.
Et, heureusement pour moi,
je viens d'une des villes les plus polluées des États-Unis,
(En riant) Houston au Texas.
Rien que dans ma ville, il y a sept sites prioritaires,
désignés par l'Agence de Protection Environnementale.
Ce sont des sites tellement pollués
que le gouvernement a considéré leur nettoyage comme une priorité nationale.
J'ai donc décidé d'aller y faire un tour
pour collecter des échantillons de sol grouillants de bactéries.
J'ai commencé à jouer avec un protocole,
qui est le nom savant pour une recette de cuisine.
Et ce que j'ai essayé de cuisiner,
c'est un milieu sans carbone, ou un milieu sans nourriture,
un environnement sans le carbone ou la nourriture habituels
dont les bactéries ont besoin pour survivre, comme nous, humains.
Dans cet environnement, je ne fournissais à mes bactéries
qu'une seule source de carbone ou de nourriture.
Je nourrissais mes bactéries de polyéthylène téréphthalate,
autrement dit, du plastique PET.
Ce plastique est le plastic le plus produit dans le monde.
Il est utilisé dans toutes sortes de contenants alimentaires,
le plus célèbre étant la bouteille d'eau en plastique,
que nous, humains, utilisons à ce jour à un rythme d'un million par minute.
En gros, ce que je faisais,
c'était de soumettre mes bactéries à un régime forcé de plastique PET
et observer si certaines arrivaient à survivre, ou mieux, prospérer.
Ce type d'expérience pourrait servir de dépistage de bactéries
qui se seraient adaptées à un milieu pollué par le plastique
et auraient développé le don super cool de manger le plastique PET.
Grâce à ce dépistage,
j'ai pu trouver des bactéries qui avaient, justement, développé ce don.
Ces bactéries avaient découvert le moyen de manger le plastique PET.
Alors, comment font-elles ?
Eh bien, c'est plutôt simple.
Tout comme nous, humains, transformons notre nourriture en sucre
pour en tirer de l'énergie,
mes bactéries font la même chose.
Cependant, mes bactéries ont réussi à opérer ce processus digestif
avec du plastique PET, dur, résistant, et pérenne.
Pour ce faire, mes bactéries utilisent une version spéciale
de ce que nous appelons une « enzyme ».
Les enzymes sont des composés simples qui existent chez tous les êtres vivants.
Il existe plusieurs sortes d'enzymes,
mais leur rôle essentiel est de faire progresser certains processus
comme celui de la transformation de la nourriture en énergie par la digestion.
Par exemple, nous humains, possédons une enzyme appelée « amylase »,
qui nous aide à digérer des amidons complexes tels que le pain,
en petits bouts de sucre que nous pouvons ensuite transformer en énergie.
Mes bactéries ont une enzyme spéciale appelée « lipase »,
qui s'attache au plastique PET, dur, résistant et pérenne,
et aide à le dissoudre en petits morceaux de sucre
que mes bactéries vont ensuite transformer en énergie.
Essentiellement, ce plastique passe
de l'état de polluant longue durée, solide et résistant,
à celui de repas délicieux pour mes bactéries.
C'est plutôt cool, non ?
(Public) Oui !
Etant donnée l'ampleur actuelle de la pollution plastique,
il me semble que c'est plutôt utile.
Les statistiques que je vous ai données
sur la quantité de déchets plastiques accumulés sur notre planète
sont impressionnantes.
Elles sont effrayantes.
Et je pense qu'elles montrent que bien que la réduction,
la réutilisation et le recyclage soient importants,
à eux seuls, ils ne suffisent pas à résoudre ce problème.
Et c'est là, je pense, que ces bactéries pourraient nous aider.
Mais, je comprends bien pourquoi le concept de cette aide bactérienne
puisse rendre nerveuses certaines personnes.
Après tout, si le plastique est partout et que les bactéries le mangent,
n'y a-t-il pas un risque que ces bactéries
se répandent dans la Nature et créent des ravages ?
En bref, la réponse est non, et je vais vous dire pourquoi.
Ces bactéries sont déjà présentes dans notre environnement.
Les bactéries de ma recherche ne sont pas génétiquement modifiées.
Ce sont des bactéries naturelles
qui se sont simplement adaptées à leur milieu pollué par le plastique,
et ont développé cette capacité incroyable de manger le plastique PET.
Donc ce processus est, en fait, naturel.
Mais, il est incroyablement lent,
et il reste encore beaucoup de travail à faire
pour comprendre comment accélérer ce processus pour le rendre efficace.
Mes recherches explorent des manières d'y arriver
grâce à une série de prétraitements ultraviolets,
ce qui veut dire qu'on inonde le plastique PET de lumière du soleil,
parce que la lumière du soleil agit un peu comme de l'attendrisseur sur un bifteck,
rendant les liens forts, résistants et pérennes dans le plastique PET
un peu plus mous et plus faciles à mâchouiller pour mes bactéries.
Au final, ce que j'espère atteindre dans mes recherches,
c'est créer un système fermé sans carbone à l'échelle industrielle,
une sorte de composteur,
où ces bactéries pourraient prospérer en milieu fermé,
avec pour unique source de nourriture les déchets de plastique PET.
Imaginez qu'un jour, vous soyez capables de jeter tous vos déchets plastiques
dans un bac, au coin de la rue,
destiné à usine de traitement de déchets plastiques alimentée par des bactéries.
Je pense qu'en travaillant dur, c'est tout à fait réalisable.
Ces bactéries mangeuses de plastique ne sont pas la panacée.
Mais, vu les statistiques actuelles, il est clair que nous, humains,
avons besoin d'un petit coup de main pour résoudre ce problème.
Parce que, les amis, nous avons un problème urgent de pollution plastique,
et les bactéries pourraient bien être une part importante de la solution.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)